hello and welcome to another three ABN
today Bible q a program this is a
program that's a rapid PACE program
where we take a journey through the
Bible based off of questions that you
have submitted so thank you for
submitting your questions to us here
it's a lot of fun you know it's kind of
a way to participate with you of course
you're part of the 3abn family and we
want to say thank you for your prayers
and financial support for your ministry
God's Ministry 3abn without you three
have been would not be able to reach the
entire world with the good news of the
Gospel of Jesus Christ so we're so glad
you've joined us for this one hour
program you know these programs go by in
a hurry it seems like kind of time
speeds up but it doesn't each one of the
Bible students here they have about
three to four minutes and uh boy it's
just it's a lot of fun to go through
your questions and your comments now I
want to give you the way that you can
reach 3abn in case you say hey I do have
a question I have a comment that I'd
like to submit for a future program
there are several ways you can do it you
can do it through email and it's by
QA at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
or you can also send us a message
through text and that's
618-228-3975 you can also do it through
Instagram which is 3avn underscore
officials so we're so glad that you have
joined us grab your bible
I've grabbed my glasses too you see that
I've been using them more and more and
I'm so thankful that I can use these
glasses to be able to see actually
clearly grab a pen maybe grab your
mobile device take notes study along
with us today joining me here on the set
I have three gentlemen that are students
of the word of God I have Pastor John
dinzi brother John Dinsey right across
me so glad you've joined us today it's a
blessing to be here and it's a blessing
to know that God is willing to teach us
every day
you know and I affectionately call you
Pastor John you know when I first came
here to 3abn oh my what's it been Pastor
it's been 24 years ago or so a long time
our Thompsonville Church where we're
kind of in between pastors and John
dinzi you are the head Elder I believe
it kind of stepped in in the Pastoral
role and kind of mentored me as a young
man and appreciate it always appreciate
always your concern for others and care
for other people and you guys are a
blessing you and your wife so thank you
praise the Lord thank you sitting next
to you is a really special person and
that's my dad I have to tell you that
Pastor Daniel moricone first time on
Bible q a you maybe have seen him on
some family worships and some other
programs but Dad is such a blessing to
have you on the program today well it's
my privilege to be on here with you what
a blessing thank you I'm going to call
you Dad okay I know you're a pastor and
he's also you may not know this he's
actually a registered nurse so he has of
course he's an ordained pastor but he
also has his nursing license and he and
my mom moved from West Virginia about a
year ago to Southern Illinois are
helping us here at 3ab and an incredible
blessing but you and Mom spent about 40
years yeah Appalachia and it's a
blessing here to have you in Southern
Illinois now thank you but next to you
is Daniel Perrin Professor Daniel Perrin
I like to call him you spent about 20
years 18 years that's right teaching
tell us where teaching in Walla Walla
Walla Walla Valley Academy teaching High
School Bibles there and a lot of fun
right yeah I know the word of God means
a lot to you but before we get going
before we open in prayer I want to just
ask your gentlemen a question
um you all have Smiles on your faces so
what do you praising the Lord for today
I'll start with you Daniel well I am
praising the Lord that some members of
my family recently returned safely from
one of the streams of light mission
trips oh very good and just great
stories about what God is doing to share
the gospel and get it into people's
lives and homes and hearts and that's
what passing out literature passing out
literature particularly the great
controversy amen praise the Lord what
about you dad what do you praise the
lord well I'm thankful that we got those
500 raspberry plants in the ground
that's good the ground dried up enough
here so that Gregory and I put those 500
raspberry plants in the ground and
they're growing nicely and so forth
praise the Lord so we're going to be
eating a lot of raspberries I think in
the coming days yes all right how about
you Pastor Johnny what do you praise the
Lord for I am praising the Lord for my
family and the blessing of the Holy
scriptures because you know you look at
today and what's happening it you see
that there's hope for us there's hope
for us in Jesus Christ amen praise the
Lord you know there's so many things to
be thankful for and I can hear you at
home as these gentlemen are mentioning
with their thankful for and praising the
Lord for what you're thankful for and
what you're praising the Lord for we
have so many things to be grateful let's
open the prayer Daniel please pray for
us dear father in Heaven lord it's our
privilege and our pleasure to come to
your word because that's where it's
revealed the love of Jesus and that's
where we see our sinfulness so we lay
that down at the foot of the cross and
we take your character Lord as we do
that day by day we give all the praise
and glory and honor to you bless us
again today through your word in Jesus
name we pray amen amen
all right before we get started I do
want to say I wanted to mention this
earlier but I do thank Ladonna she is
our producer for this Bible q a program
she does a great job organizing all of
your questions all of your comments and
I also want to say thank you because she
put you Dad on the program so your first
q a with me so that's really special so
thank you so much Ladonna all right
Pastor Johnny I'm going to start with
you this question comes from Instagram
and uh good question it says could you
please share your understanding of
Matthew chapter 12 verse 40. Jesus was
not buried for three nights is this
referring to an event other than his
death and Resurrection
good question so much very good question
and I have to say that we see that
people have come up with different ideas
trying trying to find three days and
three nights because when we look at the
Bible we see that Jesus died on Friday
sometime before the sun set
and
when you look at that you find that
there are only you can say Jesus was in
the grave two nights being Friday night
yes Saturday night and part of three
days let's go ahead and read Matthew
chapter 12 verse 40 it says 4 as Jonas
was three days and three nights in the
whale's belly so shall the son of man be
three days and three nights in the heart
of the earth so as we read the account
of Jesus we try to figure out where do
you find these three days and three
nights or do we need to find three days
and three nights what's important is
that Jesus Christ died for us and that
he was resurrected how much time he
spent in the grave it really is I'm
sorry but irrelevant because the fact is
he died for us and he was resurrected
that's what's really important but you
know people like details and they want
to know why why isn't it three days and
three nights uh well when you consider
the way the Jews consider time and you
can even go there's actually a Jewish
encyclopedia and I found that in volume
four and I even have the page number
here page
um I think it's 475.
it says that yes 475 when you look at
the word entry or the word for the entry
for the word day it says uh a a day
composed of daytime and night time and
can also be considered part of a day so
in other words they will count part of a
day as a full day even though uh
something happened for an hour or two
hours they would say that was a whole a
whole day so this is what has been
called inclusive Reckoning inclusive
Reckoning that means they count uh part
of the day so Jesus was like I said uh
two nights and part of three days but
since he was in the Grave part of the
night they counted as three nights so
that's inclusive Reckoning and so I also
wanted to point something out that this
is not something that has been this is
some something that continues by the way
uh when I go to a country I have to put
the time the the days that I was at in
that country and whether I was there
part of the day you know you arrived you
arrived like at 9 00 PM but I arrived
that day I have to count that day that I
was in that country and when I leave I
sometimes leave at eight in the morning
but I was there in that country I have
to come that I was there in that country
and it's interesting I also found that
the U.S government has a way that they
also count the same thing it says in a
document U.S IRS document by the way it
says you are treated as present in the
United States on any day you are
physically present in the country at any
time during the day and so they say
however there are exceptions to this
Rule and they go on to explain that so
this is something that continues and
when you look at the phrases used for
Jesus being in the grave in Matthew
chapter 8 verse 31 uh it uses the phrase
after three days I will rise again and
then in Matthew 16 21 he says he will be
raised again on the third day so
different phrases are used but they all
mean the same thing Jesus was in the
grave
part of three days a part of three
nights and part of three days but
inclusive Reckoning tells us that it was
three days and three nights amen and
like you said praise the Lord that he
rose from the dead amen so praise God
for that all right Dad this question
comes from Oklahoma and through email
and it comes from Amy
some people use the latter part of Mark
7 19 to mean that all food is purified
therefore it doesn't matter what we eat
please explain what Jesus meant by this
reference in the verse in the context of
the passage
wow good question yeah Amy thank you for
your question first let's go to Mark
chapter seven and you mentioned getting
it in its context and so we see in the
beginning there there were some spies
looking at Jesus and his disciples there
and that's what they were always doing
that with their job right to spy out
trying to catch them doing stuff and so
the disciples were eating without
washing their hands and this was their
tradition they were supposed to wash
their hands otherwise they would be
defiled and in verse 5 of Mark 7 then
the Pharisees and scribes asked him why
walk not thy disciples according to the
tradition of the elders but eat bread
with unwashing hands so you can see that
this has to do with tradition they were
trying to keep up with their tradition
so Jesus first of all he scolds them for
using tradition in the next several
verses there he's saying that they're
using tradition above God's Commandments
where
the uh honor your parents they had this
thing called core band where they could
use their funds for the Temple and so
that they didn't have to help their
parents so they were breaking the fifth
commandment by doing that so he's coming
after them with that
since they were coming at him and then
you know if I was coming down to verse
17 getting back to your question about
this verse 19 and when he was entered
into the house from the people his
disciples asked him concerning the pair
the parable and he said unto them in
verse 18 are ye so without understanding
also do ye not perceive that whatsoever
thing from without enters into the man
and it cannot defile him so things that
we take in won't defile so that verse 19
because it entereth not into his heart
so it's stuff on the inside of us the
heart that's what Jesus was going for in
this but into the belly and goeth out
into the drought draft or purging all
means basically whatever we take in
remember biology classes your Elementary
Canal you eat it saliva mixed with it
that goes in your stomach acid and then
it goes out right into the latrine or
the toilet and then it says it's purged
but so this actual question was actually
dealing with rather than food or Meats
it was actually doing with things in the
heart so you can see in verse 21 through
23 evil thoughts coming out of your
heart adulteries fornications those are
the things that defile us rather than
the things that we eat and if you look
at real closely at verse 19 you know as
far as purging it
purging all Meats so basically you know
when it's in the toilet is when it's
clean right Purge that's when it's all
done basically if it's broken down and
eliminated and so we were taking care of
the situation so anyway it's having
nothing to do with what kind of foods
we're eating but rather things coming
out of your heart that's what he's
dealing the heart and the mind part of
it yeah that's excellent yeah thank you
very much for the question and good
answer
all right Professor Daniel this comes
from Ruthie and the question comes via
email so it seems that 80 percent of the
New Testament is figurative why are so
few things literal
all right now God is a master
communicator and he communicates in
different ways because all Minds do not
think alike Hebrews 1 1 says God who at
various times and in various ways spoke
in the past and that reveals to us how
God communicates and so anybody who
applies themselves to understanding
scripture recognizes that God's word and
the truths that are found there are
revealed long after the initial reading
as God continues to reveal to us more
and more about how they apply to our
life today so it may seem like much of
the New Testament cannot be taken
literally so let's take a closer look at
what is in the New Testament we've got
four gospels in the books a book of Acts
this is narrative history the literal
stories of Jesus real accounts and of
course even those require us for an
in-depth understanding to move back and
forth through the books of the Bible to
see what God wants them to mean for us
today then you have the letters these
were instructions from the apostles
written to real people in real churches
about real and real situations and then
they revealed real things about their
literal lives and then with included in
both the gospels and the Epistles are
some statements teaching statements and
many of them are so clear that they
could not be anything but taken
literally this is the love of God to
keep his Commandments the dead in Christ
shall rise first is anyone among you
suffering let him pray those things are
meant to be taken literally and
understood that way some of them clearly
require us to look deeper into the Bible
and let the Holy Spirit lead us some of
Jesus Parables where he is giving a
story and then that story invites us to
look deeper and then there are those
surprising passages and these ones stand
out to us with hyperbolic language like
uh if anyone comes to me and does not
hate his father or mother wife or
children brother or sisters even his own
life he cannot be my disciples I'm not
going to deal with that one here but
there are few there are few statements
like this that clearly needs some
interpretation through the Holy Spirit
and then the Book of Revelation chapter
1 verse 1 says he sent and signified it
by his Angel to his servant John up
front we are told in Revelation that God
gives the message symbolically through
signs but why and the reason is that
this requires us then to search the
scriptures God gives the message in such
a way that forces us back into the book
to say Lord what do you want for me to
understand
it leads us to trust that God has more
for us to understand like Insider
language like a husband talking to his
wife a relationship and it reminds us
that we're in a spiritual battle and
these are like War codes written to an
army of people who need to understand
God's message for them today it
illustrates that God's message requires
us to give full attention and good study
to it and that true wisdom comes only
through God and only through much prayer
and so this is how we're to understand
the New Testament First Corinthians 2
9-14 has these statements God revealed
through the Holy Spirit and that through
the Holy Spirit we are taught comparing
spiritual things through with spiritual
and they are spiritually discerned so
literal or figurative all of it requires
us to go through the Holy Spirit to
understand what it matter means for us
today amen yeah praise the Lord yeah
great great answer and a really good
question Pastor John denzis comes from
Rosa her question was submitted via
email due children born out of wedlock
go to heaven wow serious question it's a
serious question and we think thank you
Rosa for sending that question in
I have to say that there's no one born
in this world that you can say will
immediately or will go to hell or
there's no one born that automatically
is saved everyone has a choice to make
and I praise the Lord that he has given
us scriptures to help us understand that
notice Ezekiel chapter 18 verse 20 the
soul who sins shall die the son shall
not bear the guilt of the father nor the
father bear bear the guilt of the son
the righteousness of the righteous shall
be upon himself and the wickedness of
the wicked shall be upon himself in
other words people are responsible for
their own sins
so no children born out of wedlock that
doesn't mean that they are not going to
be saved they have a choice to make and
this is why I point you to John chapter
3 verse 16 for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son
whoever believes in him will not perish
but have everlasting life you have uh
these scriptures to help us understand
that everyone has the opportunity to be
saved and it would be so
uncharacteristic of God that a child
born out of wedlock oh no this one is
destined to go to to hell he cannot be
saved no such thing is found in the
Bible that's right I uh I want to bring
you to revelation 22 17 before this
moment is over and it says and the
spirit and the bride say come and let
him that heareth say come and let him
that is a thirst come and whosoever will
let him take the water of Life freely so
everyone has the opportunity to have
salvation amen and at this point I now
go to Revelation chapter 3 verse 20
which says behold I stand at the door
and knock notice how it says if anyone
hears my voice and opens the door I will
come into him and sup with him and he
with me he or she so this is an
opportunity that every single person has
and no one can take that away from them
everyone has the opportunity for
salvation I praise the Lord that it is
that way because Satan would have us
believe otherwise but praise God God is
love and he is offering everyone the
opportunity for salvation yeah amen wow
everyone yeah amen everyone praise God
what hope what Assurance amen amen all
right Dad this this question was
submitted via Instagram and coming from
Ghana and it's from Gwen what advice
would you give if I want to be close to
God and allow him to guide my path wow
first of all Gwen I want to commend you
for this question or wanting to shows
that you're wanting to come close to God
that's right and to do what he wants you
to do
guide be guided by him
and then second
you want to hear him you want to hear
what he wants you to say that's why you
want to get close to God and that shows
that you have a humble heart a teachable
heart
and to me that's what God wants you to
have and that's his Desire by the way to
come close to you or for you to come
close to him so you guys have that
relationship that's his desire for you
also
you guys are on the same path there
and let's go to a couple of scriptures
here
as far as humility since that's you're
coming as a child or a Seeker after God
and that's what we need when we're
trying to find God so James chapter 4
and verse 6 James
chapter 4 and verse 6 says
but he God giveth Grace more grace
wherefore he saith God resisteth the
proud but giveth Grace unto the humble
he gives you his grace because you're
humble you're Desiring to know him
you're seeking him and that's what he's
Desiring for you in verse 10 humble
yourselves in the sight of the Lord and
He Shall lift you up those are two
things that you're already there I'm
kidding that by your the way you're
asking your question and then in First
Peter chapter 5
first Peter 5 verses 5 through 7
likewise ye younger submit yourselves to
the Elder yea all of you be subject one
to another and be clothed with humility
for God resisteth the proud and giveth
grace to the humble
humble yourselves therefore under the
mighty hand of God and he will exalt you
in due time
casting all your care upon him
for he careth for you then also I would
add you know reading the scriptures
reading God's word with a desire to know
what he wants you to do saying you're
committing yourself when you're reading
that he's going to speak to you through
the Holy Spirit and he's going to tell
you what to do and so with that
commitment I'm going to do Lord what
you're going to ask me to do and that
way he'll continue to guide you and then
in Psalm 37 verse 23 my last scripture
here again I just commend you for your
question
Psalm 37
and verses 23 and 24 the steps of a good
man someone that's obedient in this
context because there's none good right
none righteous the steps of a we'll say
obedient person are ordered by the Lord
and he delighteth in his way though he
fall he shall not be utterly cast down
for the Lord upholdeth him with his hand
so God bless you Quinn yeah amen
great question and good answer thank you
Professor Daniel a question coming all
the way from Alaska from Donna what does
the use of Leaven unleavened in Parables
and references in the Old Testament
stories mean literally does it have any
symbolic Sanctuary or prophetic meanings
I have a theory but I'm curious if this
topic has been discussed I bake so I
know yeast is baking soda or baking
powder considered leavening when
observed by Jewish tradition
okay there's a lot in this question here
I'll try to get through all of it in
anticipation of the Passover God asked
the Jews to bake their bed bread without
leaven and we tend to think that that is
just yeast but the primary word for
leaven comments in Hebrew refers to the
fermentation of the grain the
fermentation of the dough so even when
you combine water with dough that
process then begins fermentation that
yeast in the air actually begins to
ferment in that dose so in Jewish
tradition the process of putting water
to the dough gives you 18 minutes this
is traditional Judaism until the the
bread is then leavened can be considered
leavened so so this is why Jews remove
all grain from their house during the
Feast of unleavened bread as well as
with some biblical symbols it's not
explicitly explained and so we've got to
go to the scriptures so Exodus 30 sorry
12 verse 34 says so the people took
their dough before it was leavened
having their kneading bowls bound up in
their clothes on their shoulders so God
is releasing them from slavery in Egypt
and they don't even have time to let
their bread rise and so the leaven here
represents anything that holds us back
from immediate obedience from God to be
removed from sin in our life anything
that would prevent us from stepping out
in faith sorry can't wait can't come now
God I gotta wait for my bread to rise
gotta wait for my show to be over gotta
wait till I get that promotion gotta
wait till this works out anything that
gets in the way of saying I'm gonna walk
where God wants me to walk
all right First Corinthians 5 verse 7
and 8 Paul speaks of Leaven and calls it
the leaven of malice and wickedness but
with the unleavened bread of sincerity
and truth so the leaven represents uh
malice wickedness a picture of sin and
we know what that leaven does it just a
little bit begins to spread and begins
to grow and that's what sin does in our
life instead we're supposed to have
sincerity and Truth Matthew 16 6 to 12
Jesus is talking here and he says he
warns his disciples about the leaven of
the Pharisees and the Sadducees in Mark
8 15 he adds the leaven of Herod and in
Luke 12 1 he says Beware of the leaven
of the Pharisees which is hypocrisy and
so the leaven here spreads in our life
and it becomes a symbol of sin so when
God asks him to not put the leaven in
their bread he's saying we're going to
have a picture of something that is
sinless Leviticus 6 verse 17. this is
the only offering that God commands in
or at least the first one in Leviticus
that is not an offering of blood it's
the grain offering and it says you shall
it shall not be baked with leaven it
shall be most holy and so the blood
sacrifice represents Jesus on our behalf
but this grain sacrifice is now us
putting forth the labor to grow the
grain by God's grace he brings the
growth but then we take that and the
leaven here represents or the no leaven
in the grain offering represents our
sacrifice of a holy life to God by his
power not by our own power Ephesians 2
verse 10 says we are his workmanship
created in Christ Jesus for good works
so the leaven once again representing
sin that God wants to remove to our
lives as we then offer ourselves as a
Living Sacrifice to him in the parable
Matthew 13 33 Jesus speaks a parable and
says the kingdom of heaven and so now
Jesus is using the leaven as an
illustration of his kingdom that just
likes a little bit of sin Works its way
through everything the gospel message
just like a woman takes a little bit of
yeast hides it in the dough and then it
fills everything that's what the Kingdom
of Heaven is like for us now uh the rest
of the part of the answer the the baking
soda baking powder that's coming after
the break okay all right very good I
like it the big point is though keep sin
out by God's power and also stay tuned
to the very last portion of this program
okay I like that all right brother
Johnny this comes from T Lee and they
texted this from Tennessee if a person
is saved by grace does keeping the Ten
Commandments and the Sabbath matter
wonderful question uh well we go to
Ephesians chapter 2 verse 8 to begin it
says for by Grace you have been saved
through faith and that not of yourselves
it is the gift of God and this is
obviously what you had in mind when you
say if a person is saved by grace just
keeping the Commandments matter in the
sense of Salvation to or to to have the
right to Salvation no because you are
saved by grace is it important does it
matter to keep the Commandments do we
need to keep the Commandments it seems
to be what you are inferring and so I
bring you to First John chapter 3 verse
8 it says he who sins is of the devil
for the devil has sinned from the
beginning for this purpose the Son of
God was manifested he might destroy the
works of the devil so a person who
chooses to not keep the Commandments
then is going to be in the category of a
sinner and then this causes a situation
because the Ten Commandments identify
what is sin and so First John 3 4 says
whoever commits sin also commits
lawlessness and sin is lawlessness in
the King James version it says
transgression of the law so does it
matter yes it matters because the wages
of sin is death so if you choose to say
well I'm saved by grace I don't have to
keep the Commandments this means that
you are then not going you're going to
ignore the Commandments and you're going
to sin
does it matter yes it does because the
wages of sin is death and so in Ezekiel
chapter 18 verse 9 it says if he has
walked in my statues and kept my
judgments Faithfully he is just he shall
surely live says the Lord so
uh walking with the Lord
serving the lord and being faithful to
the Lord keeping his Commandments really
identifies who and whose side you're on
you're either on God's side or the
devil's side if you ignore the
Commandments and you sin then you are on
the devil side but if you choose to
identify yourself with God's kingdom
then you are going to choose to keep the
Commandments why because you love God
this is why Jesus says if you love me
keep my Commandments you see God has the
Commandments
summarized in two great Commandments
love the Lord your God with all your
heart with all your mind and with all
your strength and your neighbor as
yourself well who's my neighbor is it
the person next door no your neighbor is
everyone else that is not you so this is
your neighbor so I say that yes it does
matter Jesus says if you love me keep my
Commandments and notice it John 14 15
John 15 10 if you keep my Commandments
you will abide in my life of even as I
have kept my father's Commandments and
abide in his love so you are abiding in
the love of God if you keep his
Commandments first John 2 3 and hereby
we do know that we know him if we keep
his Commandments you identity identify
yourself with God's kingdom if you
choose to walk keeping God's
Commandments amen amen thank you so very
much Pastor for that answer and thank
you uh T Lee for the uh for that
question I want to remind you if you say
wow I have a question that's come to
mind or a comment that I'd like to
submit to Bible q a let me tell you how
you can do it several different ways you
can always email us at bibleqa at
3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv you
can also text us at
618-228-3975 today we did have an
Instagram submission for a question you
can do that through 3abn underscore
official all right Dad let's go to the
next question this comes from Bonnie
from Iowa sent it in via text next
why was God so harsh with Israel
Gathering Manna on Sabbath yet when
Jesus disciples were eating of the wheat
in Luke 6 this seems okay
well Bonnie thank you for that question
I want to take it in two parts we're
going to look at the Mana part first and
then we're going to go back to the loop
part second here so in Exodus chapter 16
let's turn there in our Bibles Exodus
chapter 16. and it's interesting the
Israelite people had been in Egypt for
400 years as slaves and so they probably
weren't able to keep the Sabbath I mean
the Egyptians probably didn't let them
off I mean that's just a thought there
but so God is establishing the Sabbath
with them again in other words that now
that they're free people wandering here
in the wilderness and looking at verse
19.
it says that Moses said let no man leave
it in the morning so this is when Manna
was given to them they were hungry and
so the God sent a Manna and so he's
telling them how to take care of this
man and you know they were to take just
an Omer for each person the dailies
portion and don't leave any of it till
the next morning so looking at verse 20
notwithstanding so here God had told
them don't leave anything till the
morning so think of that as they were
um
what would you say obstinate or
deliberate Disobedience notwithstanding
they hearken not unto Moses but some of
them left of it until the morning and it
bred worms
and stank and Moses was Wrath with them
or angry with them
you know it reminds me of uh when I was
a Cole Porter we had a leader talk to
her giving us a prep talk one time and
he said you have to have your daily
devotions every day you know some people
call it your daily Mana you know taking
time with the Lord and if you don't have
that you're going to go out before
people and you're going to stink we
don't want to stink so we want to take
that time with the Lord that was just a
side that was free at no extra cost and
then in verse 22 it says and it came to
pass on the sixth day that they gathered
twice as much and so then some
tattletales went hey Moses there's
people Gathering twice as much and then
in verse 23 he tells us the reason why
and he said to them this is that which
the Lord hath said tomorrow is the rest
of the holy Sabbath and this is by the
way before the Ten Commandments were
given on Mount Sinai this is when they
were hungry and God sent a manna
the rest of the holy Sabbath unto the
Lord bake that which you will bake today
and seed or boil that which you would
see and that which remaineth over lay up
for you to be kept until the morning so
God gave them that command to do that so
basically you take care of everything on
the sixth day get everything ready for
the Sabbath and then you eat that the
next day and so it didn't break breed
any worms verse 24 they laid it up to
the morning Moses bade and it did not
stink neither was there any worm therein
and then he said it was a Sabbath six
days shall he gather it but on the
seventh so it's interesting for 40 years
God was establishing the Sabbath with
the Israelite people every sixth day
there was twice as much that they could
gather and then every Sabbath that
didn't uh stink or breed worms and so
they were able to eat that so it was a
a lesson that they were learning there
and verse 27 it came to pass that there
were some that went out on the seventh
day for The Gather and they found none
and then the Lord so again this is
direct Disobedience right to the Lord
Moses how long refuse you to keep my
Commandments and my laws so they were
deliberately going against God there now
quickly run over to Luke chapter 6
verses 1 and 2.
Luke chapter 6 verses 1 and 2 and it
came to pass on the second Sabbath after
the first that he went through the
cornfields and his disciples plucked the
ears of corn so they were picking corn
and then the tradition of the Jewish
people they were actually harvesting on
the Sabbath it was okay actually to do
this gleaning you know if you walk
through and you could take enough for
that day but so that wasn't the problem
but the Jewish people were and again the
Pharisees the spies were trying to get
after them and so they were thrashing it
too because they broke it in their hands
and they ate it so
this was something a tradition of theirs
again so God is telling them or Jesus is
trying to get rid of all of that uh
cumbersome stuff that they had put on
the Sabbath to take away from the real
experience of enjoying the Sabbath that
God had intended for man and just one
last scripture here in Mark 2 27 and he
said unto them the Sabbath was made for
man and not man for the Sabbath
therefore the son of man is Lord also of
the Sabbath so he made it for a blessing
not to be taken away from all of the
cumbersome amen thank you thank you yeah
good question thank you Dad
this uh Daniel comes from Cameron who
wrote Deuteronomy 34 verses 5 through
12. all right Deuteronomy chapter 34
Verse 5 to 12 tells about Moses's death
if these are the books of Moses how
could Moses have written about his death
and the events that came after his death
there are two options either Moses wrote
it or someone else
if Moses wrote it then God would have
had to have shown Him prophetically in
Advance Moses writing with tears the
circumstances of his death could God do
that Psalm 103 verse 7 says he made
known his ways to Moses his acts to the
children of Israel and we're told that
Moses was a prophet Deuteronomy 18 15
tells us that God had already revealed
to Moses events from before his birth in
fact before any humans had come into
existence God could certainly reveal
what would happen after his death as he
revealed to Abraham what he was about to
do in Sodom and Gomorrah Deuteronomy 34
verse 1 says that God took Moses up to
the top of Mount Nebo and the Lord
showed him all the land God is showing
him here in Vision because he couldn't
see all the land and this is not just
the dirt but the prophetic prophesied
land and the events that God would take
his people through God is showing him
Envision so God could certainly show
Moses what was about to happen which
agrees with numerous biblical statements
calling these the laws of Moses or the
Books of Moses and Jesus in Matthew 19 7
and 8 says that Moses is the one who
wrote them on the other hand Deuteronomy
34 verse 10 says but since then there
has not risen in Israel a prophet like
Moses whom the Lord knew face to face so
if it was someone else whoever this
someone else was they would have also
had to have received this information
through inspiration by God because Moses
was alone up there on the mountain so
either way these are God's inspired
words and the other suggestions put
forward there's there's numerous other
suggestions but some people say Ellie
user who is the high priest after Aaron
some say Joshua who is the leader God
shows after Moses but does it matter
ultimately we can suggest who the author
might have been but we must trust that
God is the one who had his hand on
inspiring writing and collecting these
so then the real question is will we
trust and obey the words that God has
placed before us amen yeah that's a good
question thank you great answer great
answer there Pastor John Dinsey this uh
good question
the Bible talks about the kingdom and
Paradise
where is Paradise
it is a good question let's go to Luke
chapter 23 verse 43. and this is where
Jesus says uses this word paradise and
Jesus said to him
now I have to point out that Jesus is
here on the cross and there are two
thieves beside him and he's and one of
them said Lord remember me when you come
into your kingdom Jesus said oh surely I
say to you today you will be with me in
Paradise so what is this paradise
actually this word is used about three
or four times in the New Testament and
the word comes from a Greek word called
paradesos and looking into the
definition you can see that it means a
park
uh like Eden a place of future happiness
which includes the paradise that Jesus
is talking about but it can also mean
like a a forest preserve-like area that
was even reserved for hunting so we take
that Jesus is not talking about a place
of hunting but he's talking about the
place of heaven and we're going to see
that very clearly here as we continue in
second Corinthians Chapter 14 verse 4
Paul is talking and he says that he saw
a man that was caught up to Paradise
notice this in second Corinthians 12 4
how he was caught up into paradise and
heard
inexpressible Words which is not lawful
for a man to utter so where was Paul
caught up it says if you read the
context he says he was caught up to the
third heaven so this gives us an idea
that this paradise that Jesus is talking
about is in heaven
so let's go now to Revelation chapter 2
verse 7. notice what it says there he
who has an ear let him hear what the
spirit says to the churches to him who
overcomes I will give to eat from the
Tree of Life which is in the midst of
the paradise of God so where is this
tree of life it's in the midst of the
paradise of God now we go to Revelation
verse 1 and 2 and it says and I saw a
new Heaven and a new Earth for the first
Heaven and the first Earth War passed
away and there was no more sea and I
John saw the holy city New Jerusalem
coming down from God out of Heaven
prepared as a bride adorned for her
husband and there is talking about the
New Jerusalem and where is this this
tree of life is in the New Jerusalem so
the paradise that we're talking about
here is in heaven itself this is what
Jesus is talking about he was not
talking about uh
there is there is some Jewish idea that
there was a place called Paradise in the
grave and we don't have time to talk
about that you should send a question
about that we'll continue this
discussion yeah very good question
though and thank you Pastor Johnny for
again a great answer from the word of
God
this question comes from Donnie I have
read the book of job more than once but
still do not understand if job had 10
children or 20. how many children did
job have that's a good question there
Donnie 10 or 20. let's see let's go to
Job chapter one
and verse 2 it says
and there were born unto him seven sons
and three daughters
and then you recall the story there in
the first couple chapters of job there
where Satan was trying to show that you
know job wasn't that good of a guy it's
only because God's protecting him is why
he was doing good just kind of for
selfish purposes so we can see that he
started off with seven sons and three
daughters
and it sounds like they might have been
having a party or something like that so
and God says it's okay to do stuff to
job just don't kill him so jumping down
to verses 18 and 19 it says while he was
yet speaking there came also another and
said thy sons and thy daughters were
eating and drinking wine and thy eldest
brother's house and behold there came a
great wind storm from the Wilderness and
smote the four corners of the house and
it fell upon the young men and ladies to
the daughters they were dead and I only
am escaped alone to tell thee when you
look at that where it says men it can be
both male and female so they were all
killed there that was terrible and took
away all of his camels and so forth like
that but okay in the second half of his
life there after all of those amazing
things when you read most of job was a
discussion between all those people
but um the second half of his life going
to chapter 42 this is the last chapter
of job and then in verse 12
says so the Lord blessed the latter end
of job more than his beginning
for he had
14 000 sheep and 6 000 camels and a
thousand yoke of oxen and a thousand she
asses and then it just kind of puts it
right in here it says he had also seven
sons and three daughters so it sounds
like he had again more children and it
happened to be seven sons and three
daughters wow and it's kind of
interesting I just thought here if
you're ever having a trivia question
here in verse 14 and he called the name
of the first these are the daughters
Gemma and the name of the second kazia
and the name of the third Karen hoppak
something like that and then in all the
land where no women where no women found
so fair as the daughters of job and
their father gave them inheritance among
the Brethren so basically he got to be
known for his beautiful daughters that's
pretty neat it doesn't even mention the
names of the guys there but thank you
for the question so it sounds like he
had 20 kids all together
well you know the story of job is
amazing the blessing of daughters yeah
amen that's right you have a number of
daughters don't you yes
okay this question comes from Michigan
from Dottie and Daniel the question is
this how many times does the Bible
mention God telling us to Remember The
Seventh-Day Sabbath okay imagine you're
working in an office and your boss over
the loudspeaker makes an announcement
whatever the announcement might be all
right and then the next day you come to
work and that same announcement is
printed out on a memo and it's posted on
the wall and then you see it well it's
over here too it's post on that while
you go into the restroom and it's on the
little bulletin board in there it's on
the mirror you get an email in your your
inbox reminding you of that announcement
and you might start to think wow why
does my boss keep saying this over and
over and over again yeah your boss said
it once and now it's just being repeated
to make sure that you remember it all
right when God warned the wicked world
through Noah through Noah's preaching
and through his life because he's called
a righteous man in God in the generation
Noah is just repeating what God had
already said in the Garden of Eden uh
Nehemiah in chapter 13. he leads the
people back to worship on the Sabbath as
God commanded and he's just repeating
what God spoke all along Jeremiah
chapter 17 another Prophet read through
that chapter and look as he brings the
Sabbath up he's just repeating again
what God spoke all along Ezekiel chapter
20 and 23 and 46 the Sabbath again he's
just repeating all right Hosea and Amos
just repeating what God said once wrote
with his own finger and added no more
and it did not change Jesus then honors
the Sabbath Luke 4 16 as was his custom
all right and when Jesus does this he's
simply repeating and illustrating what
he himself established
when God said let there be light he
didn't repeat it it just happened when
God said to Lazarus come forth out of
the Tomb Lazarus didn't wait for it to
be asked a second time he just did it
and when Jesus calls us out of Darkness
Into His Marvelous Light
he sometimes has to repeat it
because of all the created world we
alone who have the power to choose we
must be coaxed sometimes to realize the
blessing of God's love so every time the
Bible refers to God's law it's reminding
of his us of his whole law including the
Sabbath every time the Bible refers to
breaking the law to sin that's breaking
the whole law including the Sabbath when
Jesus went to the Cross dying for sin
he's dying for the breaking of God's
whole law including the Sabbath we find
the Sabbath reiterated there again at
the cross
sometimes children will hear an
instruction for their parents from their
parents and they'll think they'll wait
let's see if my parent really means it
maybe they'll repeat it over and over
again and if the annoy be long enough
then I'll finally start to to obey them
if they really mean it well how many
times should a parent have to ask let me
ask you parents how many times should
you have to ask before your child obeys
you what do you think you're looking at
my dad
could be one time how many times should
God have to ask us
one time well God did explicitly
reiterate the Ten Commandments in
Deuteronomy 5 to a new generation so
that all would know that his law does
not change from one generation to the
next to the next his way of love does
not change and let's hear that right
here remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy six days you shall labor and do all
your work but the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord are God Amen in it
you shall do no work you nor your son
nor your daughter nor your male servant
nor your female servant nor your cattle
nor your stranger who is within your
gates for in six days the Lord your God
made the heavens the Earth the Seas and
all that is within them and then he
rested on the seventh day therefore the
Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
Sanctified it he said it once what a
blessing that we can hear it over and
over again amen wow praise the Lord what
a great great way to end I love the
Sabbath day and I want to remind you you
know these programs we realize they go
by in a hurry the questions are
submitted these gentlemen here do a
great job of answering them within three
to four minutes but we know we can
expound upon them a lot but I want to
encourage you to go to 3abn plus now
this is a really special app it's a
special place to go it because it has
video on demand now what that means is
that you can take this program or any
other Bible q a Sabbath school program
other where other programs you can go to
3abn plus dot TV and then you can go
there and you can play the program you
can pause it you can then hit rewind you
can play it again you can pause it and
that's a blessing because then you can
take notes and you can study along with
us you know I want to encourage you
today before we go to our break Pastor
John Dinsey mentioned earlier Revelation
chapter 3 verse 20. it's talking about
Christ it says behold I stand at the
door and knock If any man hears my voice
and opens the door I will come in and
will sup with him and he with me you
know today is the day of salvation it's
wonderful to have Bible knowledge but
don't forget to make Jesus Christ your
savior of your life we're going to take
a quick break we'll be right back with
some closing comments
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
thank you again for joining us for
today's Bible q a program we're going to
end here with some closing thoughts
Professor Daniel all right now back to
the question about leaven and baking
soda good good yeast is not the only
agent that makes dough expand yeast does
it through the biological process of
fermentation breaking down the sugars
releasing carbon dioxide but there are
also some other agents like baking soda
which is a mineral that does it through
non-biological processes of releasing
gas so if you uh if you interpret the
the leavening simply as making the dough
expand and that includes everything but
the original language that refers to the
fermentation process and so it includes
just the yeast and other things that are
biological processes either way don't
get hung up on that look to the meaning
trying to allow God to remove Sin from
our lives amen how about you Dad closing
thoughts well just thank you for
allowing me to come on here with these
professional people here that know all
these answers like that I was thankful
to be a part of you guys group there
thank you so much thanks for the prayers
of everybody it's a blessing dad you
know to study the word of God I mean
ever since we were little you've
encouraged my sister and myself to study
the word of God and make it personal for
our own life so thank you so much for
how you raised us as well how about you
Pastor Johnny closing thoughts about
Paradise we read in Revelation 2 7 to
him whoever comes I will give to eat
from the Tree of Life which is in the
midst of the paradise of God revelation
22 1-2 says and he showed me a pure
River of Water of Life clear as Crystal
proceeding from the Throne of God and of
the lamb in the midst of his streets and
on either side of the river was the Tree
of Life
so there the paradise of God is with God
in heaven and in the New Jerusalem yeah
amen thank you both very much thank you
for making the word of God clear you
know and I we thank you at home for also
submitting your questions and comments
to us here at 3 again and don't forget
to make the word of God part of your
personal daily walk with him open the
scriptures pray to the Holy Spirit and
say God show me your way today as you
know I like to always read second
Timothy 2 15 study to show thyself
approved unto God a Workman that needeth
not to be ashamed rightly dividing the
word of Truth God bless you we'll see
you next time
[Music]
foreign